winds in the east
missed coming in
like something is brewing
about to begin
ladies and gentlemen we are beginning
our descent into los angeles
welcome mrs pl traverse to the city of
angels it smells like jasmine chlorine
introducing the creator of our beloved
mary poppins who else mary poppins never
ever just met
now where is mr disney
here you are not last
oh my dear gal
you can't imagine how excited i am to
finally meet you
oh walt did you go to call me walt mr
disney was an old man isn't that right
dog absolutely come here
now here you are and look at you
i could just eat you up
well that wouldn't be appropriate
i made a promise to my daughters that i
would make your mary poppins fly off the
pages of your books
i promise them pam i know what she's
going to do to her she'll be cavorting
and twinkling he can't make the film
unless you grant the rights
now let us begin
give it a whirl
what's happening what are you doing
constables responsible now how does that
sound
responsible
is not a word we made it up
well
unmake it up
the banksy's house doesn't look like
that no no it's all wrong it's all wrong
stop mary poppins is not for sale i
won't have her turned into one of your
silly cartoons says the woman who sent a
flying nanny with a talking umbrella to
save the children you think mary poppins
has come to save the children oh dear
i'm wondering what i have to do to make
you happy you know you've never been to
disneyland and that's the happiest place
on earth
well when does anybody get to go to
disneyland with walt disney himself
there he is where did she come from
mary poppins and the banksies they're
family to me mary poppins was a real
person so it's not the children she
comes to save it's their father
i won't disappoint you i swear every
time a person walks into a movie house
they will rejoice
the boys have come up with an idea i
think's gonna make you happy you didn't
bring me all the way here to tell me
that oh no i had a wager i couldn't get
you on a ride i just won 20 bucks yeah
bye